dear chess friends welcome back to the
official broadcast of the world cup and
here we have the world champion with us
uh hello magnus um would you
be so kind to share like your thoughts
first of all of course about the opening
uh were you surprised by bishop
b2 uh yeah i was in general um
uh in general i mean i just didn't know
it very well
so i cannot believe that you know so
what
happened is that um
i thought if he goes for one of these
sidelines like a4 and so on i shouldn't
be
too worried so i thought you know i'll
play something and i'll probably
be a bit worse but we'll get the game
and that's fine by me
uh but i mean i guess it's easier said
than that than done um
so my only worry here is that what i was
spending
uh i was spending a lot of time uh which
wasn't
um wasn't ideal um anyway i mean
i came up these are just the ideas that
we were showing you so
came up with uh yeah our queen d7 is
normal and here
i was just trying to find a way to to
avoid
these positions because it's just
a little bit better for white and
obviously
very very limited in terms of winning
chances um
so instead yeah so instead
um no that that's i know it could be
very confusing yeah
it's a bit confusing so so nighttime
uh we have uh yeah we have that here
knight a5
bishop a2 he seems to be surprised by it
by c5
um i guess b4 is also
a normal option here i i mean i don't
know knight e2
there were there was also i mean bishop
g5 and knight d5 which
were serious options uh anyway 92 96
yeah knight g3 and here
um again i'd had um
like an hour 20 on the clock i might
have
done something else but actually we were
discussing and nigel said that this was
one of the most principled
uh continuations to play yeah for sure
like
i've certainly set up everything to to
play d5 but
there were also other ways to play like
i could go
rookie rookie 8 bishop to e8 and then
knight e7 and so on
also knight d8 knight e6 but maybe then
i've lost some
some time also i could simply take on a4
which
looks um a bit strange but i don't think
he's getting
um the pawn back very very soon uh and
if c3 i had knight a5
um so this was this was certainly
certainly an interesting option uh but
then again i thought
ba4 i i'm gonna play this with um yeah
35 minutes left and
and then there's going to be all sorts
of
attacking ideas and um it's not going to
be clarified so that's why i decided to
go for d5 uh knight d5 i thought
i might be a little bit worse but it
should it should in general be
uh drawable um c3 yeah so
if he takes i think takes bishop of six
it should be
should be fine um yeah so this was
interesting
c3 um
here is the game here is the game yeah
c3
here again there was um f6 possible but
it's always a bit unpleasant some with
some knight h4 coming like
i have to calculate whether i can play
g6 and
just even the ideas like a b and queen
b3 um
not not in this exact case because the
knight of five but
yeah exactly that's yeah anyway i i
i decided that i should give up a pawn
and i know that etienne has played these
positions so many times as black so
maybe he'd be more comfortable as black
than
than as white because this was also
but in general yeah this is very very
interesting
so it's also rook g5 at this point
and then yeah then who knows
i i could go h6 but i wasn't very keen
on finding out if there's uh more than
if there's more than a perpetual or not
here for uh
for white uh so my intention
was was to play bishop e7
and and if you're okay yeah rookie five
of course
i have to i have to repeat um
and i'm not sure if there are better
options for white there at least i
couldn't
um couldn't see it um
oh no this is not the game so he's
taking on b5
which is a very interesting moment
because now his bishop on a2
is in huge trouble in many many lines so
maybe these lines work better if he
doesn't take on b5
um but yeah we didn't really uh
i didn't have too much time yes yes
think about it
already anyway what happened uh
so where is the game here yeah announces
uh bishop f4 and before like i've
i didn't um i didn't see
it in a direct way but i i thought in
general
two bishops normally there should be
more or less enough compensation
so 94 yeah queen c7
i think is uh is probably uh
important uh let me see
uh where do we have the game it's g3
yes sorry we have it here like let me
clear
maybe here like here g3 yeah g3 was
maybe not forced uh not forced at all
um were you considering another maybe
there was queen h5
maybe here i can take on d3 yeah i don't
know why
yes you have to get rid of all this uh
oh
okay yeah rook d3
i don't know maybe maybe this this
worked like if
here i have g6 and i can take an h2
and i should be completely fine um
yeah but g3 was
very very risky since he's always
opening up this
big diagonal and here here i felt
yeah bishop b5 um
f4 yeah i don't know don't know what
else to
to play if queen h5 now i can go g6 i
should be comfortable
uh so f4 bishop d6
um queen h5
queen c6 um magnus i'm sorry could we go
back here we considered a number of
options and maybe
f5 uh yeah this f5 this was interesting
if
i can go c4 if he goes f6 i go rook
e8 i think and
yeah stop me if i'm blundering something
well actually we haven't analyzed this
with the computer so it's it's very
important i thought in general like i'm
i'm playing with many more pieces here
so i should be doing great
that was my my main main point and this
rookie 8 is important since now
obviously i'm
never never getting mated
so uh i i thought i was doing great here
okay maybe maybe it's not clear
then yes uh yeah for
see if there was also d4 but
maybe i can even consider rook a8 now
uh because yeah rookie one uh rookie i
think bishop b1 maybe he gets what he
wants
but i thought rook a8
um so then we uh you scroll yeah
scroll down yeah so uh
c4 yeah yeah c4 this one
here that's the game when you see these
moves
so c4 yeah now i was already feeling
very
very comfortable d4 i don't see what
else um
yeah and i could go i could go f5 but i
didn't see
i didn't see the way here more than a
perpetual and
we tried something like to play in a
position away but maybe there was not
enough like queen h1 queen of three then
take out and then take
um bishop t yeah yes bishop d5 and just
uh to create some mating threats but
yeah
but maybe but i i thought my position
was very good
even without um
yeah if it takes just queen d6
i mean his bishop is dead and his king
is
forever weak so i don't think he can
survive this
um so what was yeah so another critical
point because i think
later yeah okay let's uh i mean he also
had knight d2 but i think also there i
was doing
doing very well uh yeah this d5 was
this i i think i should have just gone
queen b6 here
uh to be honest it was very very
tempting to
to sack them but then that was the idea
which was mentioned by nigel did it work
like knight f6 here
for trying for some perpetual then you
take
queen g4 uh king hye and queen of five
f5 does it work actually we we're not
sure maybe you will
uh clear this for us
maybe it does it was a very good yeah i
mean
moves like bishop e5 bishop f4 but then
bishop
b1 and then bishop b1 no but
and then you can take and check probably
yes yeah
and if he if it takes and now he should
be one
you can run with your king probably yes
a rookie one
must be mate yeah so this actually
didn't work
i mean it's not immediately obvious that
it's made
it should be made
oh yeah yes it's made bishop d2 or
yes to give up the queen at least
um yes rookie one it was a very
important moment
yeah maybe this was working like d5 was
in general a shock to me also there was
yeah so yeah quindi there was also a
bishop c5 here and
just going away um
but i thought here he's at least somehow
somehow hanging on yes he's very his
king is very exposed of course
but i don't know some g4 maybe and
queen g3 i was not so sure if
if this was um this was something big
but
i i somewhat i actually didn't
i didn't see a win after after
the queen sack but i i thought it would
be very very difficult for him
and so the his last mistake probably was
uh when he played queen g5
did he have a defense here uh yeah so
i think a little bit later so king
king f1 uh when he i played um
yes bishop c8 queen g2
yeah yeah uh yeah here maybe
yeah queen d5 was uh this was the last
moment maybe you could go queen c7
um because yeah when he goes queen d5
rook d8 is just all over
um maybe he could have
maybe you could have somehow saved the
game here bishop f5
queen queen c5 back
bishop e4 and maybe king h king h3
it still looks lost to me like rook b8
rook a8 and
now i'm finally finally escaping
but maybe there was some some practical
some
yeah maybe there was some study like way
for him to hold but i didn't see it
here also i thought he should have gone
back as a matter of fact there was no
need to play queen c5
and i i was going to go for
for this and i thought this was winning
uh but i i when i played bishop e6 uh of
course i wanted to repeat moves once
with uh queen g2 and bishop f5 back
before
some time because i was pretty pretty
short of time always
uh congratulations yeah anyway i just
wanted to
it has i thought the final position was
really
nice because um i mean
after kg7 of course everything is
protected and
and i was even going to play bishop h5
at some point to protect f7 and
the position could not be more solid and
of course there's no no hope for him
uh thank you magnus this was such an
important win with black actually what i
wanted to know that yesterday you had to
go through such a grueling tie break
so we saw a sign of relief of course
after you won a match
and how well how do you go and how do
you sleep and prepare for the next one
no of course i was really tired
yesterday
evening as well but yeah i had a i had a
decent night's sleep i didn't know what
to expect today to
be honest since satyanas played four
tiebreaks in a row so i thought he would
need the rest so
i mean frankly i thought he was just
going to
try and force a draw uh and then to play
sharply
to give himself a rest day and to to
play sharply as as black you know hoping
like what ajax did hoping that i'm i
make uh make a mistake in
um in a sharp position i thought
that was um that was going to be his
strategy uh obviously we got a sharp
game this time um instead but
i think i was never in particular danger
okay congratulations
and good luck thank you and we will be
back in a few seconds with nigel short